federal judges ordered the release of
some of the material withheld when the
mother report was made public
it's about former national security
adviser Michael Flynn and a phone call
that he had with Russia's US ambassador
now this could reveal how others tried
to obstruct Muller's investigation Paula
Reid is at the White House with the
latest on this story Paula good morning
good morning Gail this is the first time
a judge has ordered the Justice
Department to reveal portions of the
Muller report that had been kept secret
Mike Flynn and his attorneys say there
were multiple instances where people
connected to Congress or the Trump
administration reached out to Flynn and
his team in a way that could have
impacted his cooperation with the Russia
probe the public version of the malla
report reveals that one of those people
was one of the president's personal
attorneys who reached out to Flynn's
team in November 2017 and left a message
asking for a heads up if Flynn had any
damaging information about the president
a Flynn has a recording of that message
and a judge has ordered that a
transcript of the message be released to
the public the Flynn is currently
awaiting sentencing for lying to the FBI
about his contacts with Russian
officials before President Trump took
office but Democrats are already seizing
on these new details to renew their
calls for the full unredacted Muller
report to be released to the public
all right Paula thank you very much you
know the president said when when Mike
Flynn was caught up in this he said I
feel very badly for him you might not
feel so badly for him now but this is
you know the questions of obstruction
there were these 10 instances and one of
them was do you dangle the potential for
a pardon or do you do things to try to
get people not to talk and so it's
fascinating as you focus in on these
individual instances but we'll see if it
actually leads to anything plus it'll be
interesting to see what he has to say
about Michael Flynn now as you point out
he said yeah he felt badly for him he
feels badly until it looks like that
you're going to do something that would
hurt the president in some way yeah
we'll see I think it peel back any more
of this redacted portrait ethanol which
makes it even more important that Robert
Muller testified that we get a chance to
hear from him a lot of people want to
hear from you
most they do Thank You Paula